perhaps more than ever this year's FIFA
comes down to the little details if you
played last season's game then things
this year will look very familiar but
look at it this way
FIFA 15 is FIFA 14 executed with style
and elegance giving the game a sense of
refinement that was lacking last season
if last year's game was a skeleton of
what FIFA wanted to achieve over the
course of this console generation then
consider FIFA 15 but first layer of meat
on top of that
to be champions that certainly helped
applause many will be pleased to see the
return of the excellent ornament mode as
well as improvements to FIFA's
long-suffering goalkeepers but the
improvements to keepers are largely
aesthetic with their new animations
making them instantly more lifelike in
terms of both looked and behavior but
while they're much improved actions add
to the visual quality of FIFA 15 they
don't disrupt the established difficulty
associated with netting a goal having
said that it is now somewhat easier to
score the kind of goals that you'd
expect to see in end of season highlight
reel goalkeepers might be that much
better at stopping long shots but truly
outrageous efforts seem to find the
twine more often than you'd expect the
formation and ideology of the team
you're playing against makes a
significant difference to whether you
can get a shot off though when playing
against the AI and one of the higher
difficulty settings be prepared to
combat a greater range of tactical
philosophies and has been seen in a
football game up to this point with
teams drastically changing their
approach depending on the circumstances
they're gonna have to build from the
back from the goalkeeper menus have been
reworked to allow you to make these
kinds of changes more quickly and easily
with big bold icons being the design
order of the day the options available
here are in no way is exhaustive as in
the likes of a football manager but they
at least provide a simple means of
having your players move in a way that
suits your favorite style Gabri starts
with Argentina in complete control in
truth
FIFA is such a mainstream proposition
that tactical options a great depth and
complexity would be counterproductive to
what the series is trying to achieve the
goal with FIFA 15 is to replicate the
most interesting parts of what you see
on TV not to make you feel like a
football manager or central defender
grinding out a tough one goal victory on
a bitter winter night that would be too
realistic and not exciting enough this
is also felt in the supremely popular
FIFA Ultimate Team mode in which star
players are now available on short loan
periods for those times when you can't
afford to purchase them outright rather
than grind out those tough early
victories using your team of journeyman
foot
all's you can now just loan the likes of
messy and Ibrahimovic immediately making
you feel like the manager of a star team
increasingly however FIFA is all about
online play and it's there that the
focus on big shots and attacking
football comes into its own
scoring a spectacular goal is all the
more satisfying against you and player
especially if that person is a friend
that you can taunt after the fact the
new consoles video sharing ability now
means you can share the moment with
everyone else that you know online too
after all nothing makes you feel more
like a star than sharing your
game-winning goals on your parents
Facebook page right into the corner by
the post
once the final whistle is blown
that's what fifa15 does best it makes
you feel like a star
goalkeepers may appear more skillful but
spectacular goals are frequent enough to
make you believe that you're incredible
at defeating them tactical options have
just the right amount with depth to
allow you to change the course of a game
and call yourself a genius for doing so
but not so much that you're at risk of
confusing yourself ultimate team still
requires you to grind to put together a
top team baloney in great players lets
you perform magic instantly such an
approach might not have an enormous
amount of depth that's not so much of an
issue for a series that sees one core
release every year if you're looking for
football that is exciting exaggerated
and immensely entertaining FIFA 15 is
the game to get the balls ball into an X
just like the video game isn't it the
way it's landed at his feet